hi my name is Yahweh God today I will
present three different cases from
industry and how they have used sister
model in three completely different
applications one from helicopter landing
one from precision medicine and one from
producing clean energy thank you my name
is Yan record and well I have this I
think they're the toughest schedule like
9 a.m. today it's kind of a tough and
then the last one today is also a tough
one to have because kind of people tend
to to want to sleep this Friday morning
for some reason and anyways I'm going to
present on system or in industry the
idea is to give an idea of how you can
actually use system over and evolved
from language to solve real use cases so
I won't do any you won't see like any
lines of code or things like that that's
not the purpose of this but hopefully
you will see what type of things you can
accomplish with a software and it's
based on on work that has been done by
by consultants that we have so it's
Michael for square Marcos dal hookah met
again and then well I'm there because
I'm I'm taking the credit by presenting
it's actually the same case they I was
presenting education before and I hadn't
done the work present to CC a new new in
system other I didn't do that work I
just take the credit that's my thing
ok so let's start with this so system or
is used in a wide variety of areas which
is both good and bad because sometimes
people don't really identify themselves
with it as it can range from things like
an a fighter aircraft to medicine and
because behind the scenes all these
things can be described in differential
algebraic equations and if you only look
at the math it's kind of the same it's
just that the X represents something
else happens to represent temperature in
one case and let's say velocity in
another case and what I will do I will
show examples from four
different companies cyber oh they're
dull that drone up there in the middle
and I will show a project where they try
to design a landing system so they can
land autonomously on a ship when there's
heavy heavy waves then I'll show an
example from a company called clean
energy and you can guess what they are
doing what the type of things they're
doing clean energy and then we have the
CIB which is a research group in Linlin
shipping where we are based and
AstraZeneca pharmaceutical company that
are using system water for diagnosing or
estimating liver function and I'll come
back to why that is important so three
completely different cases but all of
them also have the same solution to
reach their goals they're using
model-based design with the Volvo
modeling simulation suite meaning
combining system over and Wolfram
language so let's get started with the
first one
okay so side arrow what are they doing
well as I said they want to land
autonomously with drones on ship in
rough sea and how would that look like I
will show a YouTube video
don't bother really about the sound you
might so now this is not from their
helicopter because it didn't really open
when we started with the project it
wasn't landing yet that was our thing to
simulate and try it so this is kind of
conditions you're supposed to be able to
land on autonomously and we will see
here a helicopter coming in and while
the helicopter has a pilot that's also
kind of of course a bit tricky but the
benefit the pilot has let me just turn
down the sound a bit there like that the
benefit for the pilot of course is that
he can see the sea for instance and he
can see the shape so he can react to
what he's seeing but still you can kind
of realize that this is a pretty tough
thing to kind of manage right
so let's just skip forward a bit I think
around here is where he finally manages
to land so he has this guy telling him
ok now try go and it lands and connects
to the chip ok so then let's let's go
back to the cyber scenario they want to
do this autonomously as I said and
basically they are doing this is done in
four steps they have a landing algorithm
where the the helicopter has been out
there or the drone has been out there
doing some surveillance it's four four
so surveillance all of the border
basically a border here so it's standing
there saying okay I'm ready to to land
and then an officer at the or the
captain someone has to tell okay get
ready to land so then it went goes to
something called touchdown standby point
where it has to wait for bit for
everybody on deck to get ready for
whatever you have to do and then they
tell it okay now start doing your things
or to normal or automatically so what it
does then it goes to a hovering position
which i think is about ten meters above
the landing plate so it's standing there
and trying to find an opportunity where
it can land and of course it can't see
the waves but what it can do it will get
measures of the current movement for the
ship and based on those those
measurements it has to guess when it's a
good time to try to land and which
angles and so on to do that so
eventually we'll try to do that and it
lads it's pretty nice so what's the
challenge well when is it actually safe
land that's the big question of course
and how do we test this without crashing
hundreds of helicopters they're pretty
expensive because you can be pretty sure
that your first attempt
developing a control system will not be
perfect if you just develop it and try
it so then what happened is we got to
develop a model for them and and the
model looked like this we developed a
library where you have a model log of
the ship and actually of the sea
condition so kind of we we model all the
seas in the world and you have the drone
up there and yeah it's that this is
basically illustrating the command you
get from the ship so you have all these
and then they send to us the real
controller which was implemented in C
code developed by a company in
Switzerland so we get that one and then
we could plug that into our model use
that and then design your landing
algorithm or in also implement the
landing algorithm they had so using that
we could start to simulate the system in
different conditions so at this point
here was doing things in system aller at
this point we start to use the ball from
language to generate different scenarios
with this controller try to land try to
try to find a way to calculate like a
landing window for them iterating making
changes until it until it actually works
it turned out that the control system
they had to begin with it would kind of
crash more than half the times would
have been a crash so sort of like what's
kind of important to do some testing
before you actually went and doing it so
the things you could see was we could
calculate and this or not is not real
data we're not allowed to show that but
basically based on the movement of the
ship we have developed an algorithm that
detects landing windows windows of
opportunity basically for the helicopter
to try to land so it says okay from this
time on to this time on we predict that
the sea condition will be or the
basically the movement of the ship will
be
nice and you have the chance to lads so
now take your it take a try and it
starts to try and it might have to abort
if it gets a warning signal back but if
if we do a bad estimate and we don't
have time to - for instance if we would
try to land here and someone will have
this ship movement we will crash into it
and fail so then we run a bunch of
scenarios and can I make this bigger
like that and what you see here is is
basically once we run here 0 to 180
degrees it says it's how the ship is
positioned in relationship to the waves
and these curves here show basically
it's also we have waves that have a
hundred fifty meter wave length and and
four meter Heights on average and then
there is a kind of stochastic process
and then we can see here on this scale
here is how much the ship is tilting as
every point when we're actually landing
so we're performing simulations we can
find out that the median of these
landings will be within this kind of
area and what we know is that if it's
less than seven degrees or something
like that then it's safe but it turns
out that for some angles here a against
the waves the maximum where kind of tilt
for the vessel is pretty big so that's
of course terrible so tell it tells us
that okay if we're actually on which
need to be within these angles here to
be safe and with these these angles
because in these angles there are
chances that will get tough to tough
conditions to be able to land and based
on that we can then and I'll show this
very quickly
we can then do a simulation and see how
the helicopter lands let me just kind of
skip here because I will be tight on
time okay so it's bored stared lights up
for it and then it lands so basically
that's what it does and it turned out to
be very successful at the end okay so
that's one scenario next one and it's
cleaner here so their goal to create
clean energy how do they do that
with a so-called concentrated solar
power system does anybody know what that
is
one that's good I never heard about it
before this so this is basically how it
works you have a big parabolic dish that
concentrates solar power into cavity and
in that so that cavity becomes hot of
course and that heat is used to power
Stirling engine the Stirling engine then
is connected inside the box you see
there with a kind of it looks like an N
kind of that's where the Stirling engine
in and then you have a generator so that
is connected to a generator and then the
generator generates the electricity so
that's that's the basic concept so some
challenges that clean energy had was
they wanted to know where is it where do
they how the biggest loss of energy in
the system so they can optimize it what
part should be modified for maximum
profit what is the predicted profit of X
number of dishes in place why with
weather said and so on so have point of
different questions that I wanted to
answer and also things like how would
how would specific system work on a
specific location so yet again what they
did together with us they developed the
model in system modeler so the model
contained the parabolic antenna the kind
of and here is and we had the cavity
that will be used to heat the Stirling
engine that then connects to the
generator and then some surrounding sea
systems around that like cooling systems
and so on so they do this then they can
synthesize the controller
yes that's we did with it with a cleaner
G or with a cyber project they simulate
the system and can test scenarios like
okay what if we move this system from
Australia to Dubai how will work can we
make changes so it works better in Dubai
then it would be would do otherwise
and in this case they didn't only need
to change weather data of course and
apply it on the same model and I will
see how it works and then they make
changes iterate and learn from that if
you look at the results what we see here
the blue dots correspond to measure
signals from operation the green dots
are simulations all the same so you can
see that the relationship and what you
see is power output so the power
estimated power output from the
simulation is following pretty well the
actual output there are a couple of
outliers there in the in the operational
output and there are probably
measurement so the probability
simulation is more accurate than a
measurement in that case and then they
have their own kind of metric for that
that kind of makes a some kind of
relation between the the the power and
and there and and the solar like
parabolic antenna that will have the
quote of that and to see you know but
you still see it's like a fiction so
meaning they can trust the results so
when they do a change when they move it
and test what happens in Dubai or in
Australia they can trust that this is
actually what's going to happen so now
they can start fine tuning if they want
to increase power production for
instance they can try to see can I
change the controller a bit or can i
fine-tune the heating system or whatever
they they need to do
to accomplish whatever they the the the
kind of goal is okay so final example in
so Liberty diagnosis AstraZeneca and see
maybe you are both developing methods to
diagnose oh this is actually from
another president relaxing there to
diagnose liver condition the the thing
is with liver condition is that there's
no good way to measure that today and
about five percent of Americans for
instance have bad liver condition so
it's a pretty big issue and there's no
good way of getting that how the liver
is actually functioning so of course you
want to do this and for you those of you
that don't happen to know what the liver
is it's it's much bigger than I thought
it was and probably you guys have better
know about and not only so you would we
know that it looks like but anyways what
they do is they use MRI scans for this
so they put a person into MRI scanner
but before that they let them take a
so-called contrast agent
so they take this contrast agent that
will then kind of be transported through
their body so through the blood stream
into the extracellular space into the
liver cells into the bile and so on and
it's called contrast engine because when
you pass it through the MRI scan you
will get changing colors depending on
how much you have of this specific agent
over time so here we can see at times
here is from zero
two-thirty and we can see that it goes
from very dark corresponds to how much
of this contrast agent we have so okay
that's fine
we know how some transported but how do
we know if this result represents a
health or unhealthy liver that's the
important question of course that we can
see that okay this took 30 minutes to
reach this or 45 doesn't tell us
anything if we don't really know if that
relates to healthy or unhealthy liver so
what they did again together with us
with Michael in this case was to model
of the entire system with a liver the
bloodstream and one and you have the
infusion there of of the contrast agent
well you don't really do that
with a needle but anyways yeah then you
calibrate the model with different
conditions different measurements you'd
done on on in this case AstraZeneca had
has done it'll rats and see him IV on on
humans so they the model works for for
both and so they calibrate that in the
Wolfram language to get it to run and
and then they run an MRI scan and match
a simulation with them with whatever
they they can see from the images so
basically using image processing
involved from language of of the MRI
scans they can map that to parameters in
the model and I'll illustrate what kind
of results they will see so these are
other things they will see so what we're
seeing here are two different models one
which was the original model the blue
one and then the simplified model and we
see that so very much the same result
and are the the measured contrasts from
the MRI scans so we can see in this case
that what we measured corresponds to to
the simulations of a normal functioning
liver and if we look at the slide to
reduce function of the liver this might
look like this with
good correspondence again between those
and if you have severely reduced or
something else so basically by taking
these these MRI scans and correlating
that with simulations they can see which
type of problems they have now this
works for a liver as a whole but but the
interesting liver is actually it's it's
a consists of several kind of
compartments and one part of the liver
might be perfectly healthy
well another might be unhealthy so next
step is to try to do it so you can
actually see which part of the liver is
malfunctioning or actually functioning
well so if I'll end up this by showing
it together with our scan here we can
see let's play that you can see here how
it changes color and that's basically
what we have then corrected these dots
are corresponding to the color that we
see here and this is from a rat by the
way so in that way they can now tell if
this liver is in good condition not so
the doctors know if they should take
some action or not okay so what's my
conclusion to this well three completely
different examples from different
domains different problems all we're
tackled with the same meaning model
based design so using a model and
testing different hypotheses in the
vault from language they could solve
really tricky and for me kind of really
interesting and in problems so the
question then is what could you
accomplish with model-based design so
with that I thank you very much and
before yeah right after this there's a
reinforcement learning with system order
presentation and there's a hardware lab
downstairs where you can do a bit o
sister mother thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions I have two minutes yeah
that was say we had that yesterday so
the new version 5.0 if I would say very
briefly what we've done is a first
important step to make it more even more
integrated with with Mathematica so
which you can see if we go to the
webpages nowadays we don't really
separate which parts are done in
Mathematica which parts are done in
before we present it this is done in the
system owner interface this is done in
the Mathematica interface now we're know
we're all looking at what type of tasks
are remodeling or assimilating or
analyzing and then whether there are in
in system order or in Mathematica it
doesn't really matter when you present
it because we see it as a whole and a
lot of what we did was doing those kind
of steps so you will see the 5-series
will do a lot in that direction and
there was a presentation yesterday on
the form language integration which is
part of that so what will happen is that
system over will work right if you have
a mathematic installation you don't have
a system modern you will be able to run
simulation if you get the model for
someone you will be able to run it in
Mathematica without having system
modeler and doing all the analysis
without having that so meaning if you
are developing a model and want to to to
give that to others for them to play
around with you can do that even if they
don't have a system model so it's like a
deployment for end users of your models
consumers of your models so that will
mean on the neck so that will first be
on the desktop and then will be part of
the Wolfram language on the cloud and so
on so it gives a more a better workflow
for you when you want to kind of
interact with others but then was a
bunch of other things like that are but
there's a presentation and I think you
can see these presentations online
afterwards right or you can get the
material at least I think compatible and
of course you can go downstairs and I'll
give you a bit more of a presentation
you
[Applause]